to disrupt the agricultural food desert
and begin to correct the dysfunctional food system
that we've created.
So maybe it seems like a really small countermeasure
to a big, huge problem -- just go plant flowers --
but when bees have access to good nutrition,
we have access to good nutrition
through their pollination services.
And when bees have access to good nutrition,
they're better able to engage their own natural defenses,
their healthcare,
that they have relied on for millions of years.
So the beauty of helping bees this way, for me,
is that every one of us needs to behave
a little bit more like a bee society, an insect society,
where each of our individual actions
can contribute to a grand solution,
an emergent property,
that's much greater than the mere sum
of our individual actions.
So let the small act of planting flowers
and keeping them free of pesticides
be the driver of large-scale change.
On behalf of the bees, thank you.
(Applause)
Chris Anderson: Thank you. Just a quick question.
The latest numbers on the die-off of bees,
is there any sign of things bottoming out?
What's your hope/depression level on this?
Maria Spivak: Yeah.
At least in the United States,
an average of 30 percent of all bee hives
are lost every winter.
About 20 years ago,
we were at a 15-percent loss.
So it's getting precarious.
CA: That's not 30 percent a year, that's -- MS: Yes, thirty percent a year.
CA: Thirty percent a year. MS: But then beekeepers are able to divide their colonies
and so they can maintain the same number,
they can recuperate some of their loss.
We're kind of at a tipping point.
We can't really afford to lose that many more.
We need to be really appreciative
of all the beekeepers out there. Plant flowers.
CA: Thank you.
(Applause)